like there's a there's a story by patty
mccord who was the former
chief human resource officer for netflix
she worked with reed hastings for 14
years she says
she says one day we had a meeting our
cfo brought everybody into the room
and he brings reed in and says hey guys
guess what what's that
we just crossed 5 million
subscribers at netflix and reid's like
no way
yes he says okay awesome
and we're going to celebrate this is now
i'm going to go out there and get to 10
million
everybody else was like no but we got a
celebration now that's great awesome i'm
going back to 10 minutes
the stories do is it
you know is it a level of i guess i
guess what i'm trying to get to is
okay question came the other day about
trevor lawrence being picked up as
number one and he says you know whether
i do this life is my life is not just
the nfl you know my life's big i don't
i'm sure you follow the story
you know my life's not bigger than the
nfl and then say well he's not brady
brady would never say that
right okay great and then guys came back
and says i don't care if he said that or
not he's still going to kill everybody
look at eli manning he came out and he
still won two championships right
and then you know look at wayne gretzky
wayne gretzky wasn't a guy that came up
wayne gretzky was just a master of his
craft and he just
went up there and was a phenom and he
put up stats that's
beyond anybody else has done in any
sport no one's even close
if you look at baseball football
basketball no one comes close to
redskins separation
so is there a lot of similarities
between the
the great ones all together or could
somebody just be like no i'm just going
to come and do the job
and go out there and it's cool you know
i'm going to work hard i'm going to do
my part
but i'm going gonna make it look easy
and i don't have to be like mike i don't
have to be like tiger i don't have to be
like the williams
i don't have to be like these guys i'm
just gonna come and win and if we don't
win a championship this year it's cool
we'll do it again next year but if we
don't win it's okay
it is do you buy into what they're
saying about lawrence or do you say no
to be a brady you have to be a
psychopath competitor obsessive
to want to kill the other guys i don't
want to talk about people i don't know
uh
i i i don't have a relationship with and
then i had that i haven't studied
but if you you look at all the
individuals that you've named
if you were to put them all in the same
room if you were all have them interview
here all in the same room
and you had a way to make their voices
sound
exactly the same so you didn't know who
was talking
all right they would tell you the exact
same
thing i couldn't tell if i was talking
to mj i couldn't tell if i was talking
i could talk into kobe i couldn't tell
if i was talking to wade
when you listen to brady you can't i
can't i can't there's things they
say to the media and there's things they
say
among themselves and i've been fortunate
enough to be blessed
to be in those conversations the
conversation to be in those con
to sit there and hear those
conversations on a private plane
with mj tiger
gretzky jeter to sit there and then
have them sitting together and just sit
back and just listen camera's off
they're just cameras
they're just oh my gosh and you know
they're not talking
they're they are they are so
freaking competitive
it's it's unbelievable and like i said
if you monotone everybody
the brain patterns and the way they do
things the way they pay attention to
details the way they relax the way they
execute
the way they focus it's
across the board it's across the board
that's the one thing they all
have in common they all have in common
if a psychologist or psychiatrist was
sitting in a room with
all those guys they would what would
they say mental disorders they have they
would call them what they
sociopath they would you you have a you
know every
every every single one they had actually
would have they'd have to
come up with something new they would
they would actually have to come like
that and
they would be just like you know they're
coming up with everything every
there's there's a disorder for every
they'd have to cut they'd have to come
up with something
because they would first thing they
would say
these people are different yes and you
know what different does
difference scares people different
scares people that's why everybody tries
to fit in
all right winning requires you to be
different these individuals are
different
in the way they do
things so if you like this sort of short
club from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye